what's going on guys bang bang there's a
whole bunch of stuff that happened in
the Bitcoin world this past week first
Brad Sherman representative out of
California he admitted that the US
government just prints money out of thin
air here's exactly what he said crypto
Bros make money literally by making
money and they've made over a trillion
dollars out of thin air
um they'll accuse the U.S government of
making money out of thin air maybe we do
but we're the US government
now on top of that we also had Ron
DeSantis the governor of Florida Banning
cbdc's as I've told you over and over
again Central Bank digital currencies
they scare me there's all sorts of
downsides to them like the surveillance
State the ability to print money the
ability to actually give you
personalized monetary policy like you
get high inflation and I get low
inflation anytime you give these tools
to policy makers they're going to abuse
them so I'm very very cautious around
Central Bank digital currencies and the
governor of Florida he's Banning them
out right now of course while all this
is going on we also see the lowest level
of Bitcoin on exchanges in five and a
half years this is more and more people
after they buy Bitcoin they're going
ahead and they're taking them off into
self-custody the big value proposition
of Bitcoin is not your keys not your
coins that means that people want to
have self-sovereignty they take that
Bitcoin right off of the exchange they
put it into cold storage and probably
forget about it for a very long time now
on top of that we also saw transactions
continuing to explode higher this is the
highest level of transactions since over
the bull March Market of 2021 usually in
Bear markets transaction volume plummets
but now we're seeing a drastic rise
things like ordinals inscriptions and
many others so keep an eye out on what's
going on with Bitcoin the underlying
fundamentals are telling us that we're
continuing to see Bitcoin strengthen
even though the price is hanging out
around 28 to 30 000 as we head into the
next having and that Expo Market this
usually seems to be the setup that will
lead to a higher bitcoin price in the
future hope you guys enjoy these updates
and I'll see all of you next Saturday